hey guys it's Justine and I just woke up
from a very very long nap and I had this
dream that Apple released a new version
of the Mac Studio with a brand new chip
called the M2 Ultra where they smashed
two M2 Max chips together into one
monster chip that will support 192 gigs
of unified memory and six Pro display
xdrs all at once but then I remembered
it's not a dream at all this was
announced at WWDC and uh it's actually
right here beside me the new Mac Studio
with the M2 Ultra chip
I'm sweating
actually I think I'm supposed to open it
like this I don't really know how you're
supposed to open it but
this feels right
there it is okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
look and then this just folds down
okay you're not supposed to do that that
was supposed to stay there
but now it's open so we're just gonna
slide it out
we've got our power cable here and I
think that's all that's in here
ah
ah it's so beautiful
I've been trying to think of the best
way to really test out the new Mac
Studio and if you've ever watched any of
my videos then you know that I am
currently powering my entire editing
desk setup which consists of an OWC raid
multiple backup drives two pro display
xdrs as well as the Apple Studio display
all with my maxed out 14 inch MacBook
Pro and I absolutely love it for so many
reasons but in the name of Science and
wanting to test this out properly I
thought I would bite the bullet and
replace my entire editing desk setup
with this Mac Studio right over here
okay let's set it up and we can chat
about it now the Mac Studio is so unique
in Apple's lineup of desktop computers
because it looks very similar to the Mac
Mini but a little bit taller and a lot
more powerful it can be configured with
either the M2 Max or the all-new M2
Ultra chip with a 24 core CPU 76 core
GPU and 32 core neural engine you can
choose from 64 128 or a 192 gigs of
unified memory and up to 8 terabytes of
internal solid-state storage that is
mind-blowing to create the M2 Ultra they
literally combined two M2 Max chips
together into one massive Ultra powerful
processor with 3.3 times faster CPU
performance up to 6.1 times faster GPU
performance and up to 5.9 times faster
machine learning and with all this power
the M2 Ultra can support up to 22
streams of 8K footage I mean I can't
even begin to imagine a scenario where
that would actually be necessary for me
personally but I'm sure there are many
people out there who it will be
necessary for and I'm definitely going
to put that to the test the ports on the
new Max studio also got a big upgrade on
the front it has two USBC Thunderbolt 4
ports plus an SDXC card reader and on
the back it has four Thunderbolt 4 ports
10 gigabit ethernets two USB a ports an
upgraded HDMI port that supports up to
8K res solution and of course a
headphone jack plenty of i o to connect
almost anything that your little
computer heart desires now the
configuration that I have here in the
studio is an M2 Ultra with a 24 core CPU
76 core GPU and 128 gigs of memory with
four terabytes of storage it just looks
so beautiful sitting under a monitor on
a desk now having previously already
tested out the Mac Studio with the M1
chip I already know how absolutely
incredibly powerful it is so obviously
this one is going to be able to do all
of the things that that could do and
more let's see if I can put 22 streams
of 8K into an 8K timeline
it kind of looks like a terrible layout
but don't judge my design skills I threw
this together really quick but this is
running so smooth and this is all prores
8K and I took this out of the A1 put it
in compressor converted it to prores and
here we are
I mean I think that was a pretty good
test I think the video is over see ya
just kidding there's more Armando had
this great idea he's like okay well
that's impressive but put it in an
actual timeline of
8K 10 of 10 AK streams but in a 76 800
by 43 200 timeline and having them
actually all be scaled to 8K inside of
this massive timeline I was like I see
you let's try it
streams of AK and this is full actual 8K
okay these I had to make these a little
smaller because they didn't fit but I
did add an extra one in and this is
running so freaking smooth let me just
give you a little
look at this
freaking smooth like butter
I mean this is absolutely mind-blowing
um in some apple demos they always love
to show you pixamater pixel pixelmator
Pro so I just thought I would try it
since I've never actually tried it
before so I'm going to zoom into this
little boat and I'm going to select it
hello little boat I don't like you go
away
and instantly it's gone I mean that
actually did a really good job what if I
want to remove this
oh well that's also gone maybe I'm going
to be using this app a little bit more
let's
well now I see why Everyone likes this
app remove that oh okay oh oh oh why is
this so freaking good oh I'm sold
[Music]
I'm actually gonna be traveling back to
my parents house and I have a studio
display there so what I'm gonna do is
I'm actually going to be packing up this
Mac Studio and taking it home with me so
I'm super hyped about that because I'll
be able to take this entire project fly
home and when I land I can just dock it
and this when you think about how
powerful this is for businesses for
productions for Studios to be able to
just take this and transport it from
Studio to set like it is something that
you really easily can do now if I had a
Mac Pro that's a little bit larger don't
think I could get on a plane with that
unless I had a very special Pelican case
which I feel like if anyone's gonna do
that it's 100 gonna be Marquez not me
but I could definitely see him doing
that but I can just easily put this
thing in my backpack and take it with me
anywhere all right let's load it up or
it's East Coast
East Coast parents house do you have
your passport is it in your Apple wallet
there it is it's in oh I need the power
cable
all right it's not so bad pretty light
but I don't have anything else in my bag
I still need to put my computer and my
iPad and the rest of my Gadgets in here
[Music]
so welcome to my childhood bedroom and
I'm gonna turn this into my studio I've
been sending a lot of time back home at
my parents house and having a dedicated
setup here is going to be so awesome
that's one thing that might be a little
bit different I have a little bit more
equipment in my room now I love these
little amaran lights I brought these
home for my studio so I'm able to use
this to light different things they're
so small and portable and I don't have a
lot of room in my bedroom so these are
perfect and super easy to store and of
course now with all of these upgrades
it's even more powerful than me as a
content creator YouTuber would probably
ever need for the next I don't know like
the next year until the next one comes
out all right let's get this started and
turn my bedroom into a full-fledged
media Powerhouse
[Music]
all right here she is Little Mac Studio
it's in here
oh yeah look at you it's so pretty like
I love it so much need a keyboard and a
mouse
[Music]
it just
we will never understand why
[Music]
foreign
okay so my setup is complete and it is
actually 11 p.m right now and I'm at my
parents house like I said and I have to
be kind of quiet because they're all
sleeping and of course much like when I
was a child I'm up late on my computer
now I'm posting this video tomorrow
morning so I have to finish editing it
but now this whole process luckily I
have an incredible editor Tyler who
helps me out immensely with my channel
so while I was traveling here he was
actually working on this edit already
and we use this app called post lab
which is by far the most fantastic thing
for editors especially for Final Cut
because it allows us to work
simultaneously on projects in the cloud
so he finished the first half of this
video and uploaded to post lab so now
I'm gonna go in and I'm going to
download the library and I have all of
the assets already on my computer
everything that I don't have he uploaded
a frame i o so I've already downloaded
all of those so both of us have matching
footage on all of our computers so here
we go here is the library I'm just gonna
click start editing and what's cool as
you can see here when he started working
on it and here we are time to start
editing so here's all of my clips and
everything is just running super fast
super smooth now when you do this
normally you need to re-link all of your
media and sometimes that takes a really
long time especially working with 8K
clips and a lot of high quality footage
but when I imported this in and
re-linked everything it was so fast so
Speedy like I blinked and the projects
and everything were just here and
everything appeared and it and dare I
say it was like magic so here's the
project as you can see it opened up
super fast here's our timeline
everything is just smooth
these are multi-cam Clips some of these
are 8kb Rule and it's just it's cruising
so what's awesome is this was all the
stuff that Tyler had edited and I came
in and finished the edit where I was
traveling home now the one thing that I
really wanted to try that I didn't get a
chance to while I was at home in Los
Angeles at my studio was gaming so I
have downloaded Resident Evil Village
and this will actually run natively on
Apple silicon Max so I'm so excited to
try this out so I'm going to sync my
Xbox controller to the studio this is so
easy to do you just go into the
Bluetooth settings press and hold this
little sync button there and there it is
we're synced so now with this M2 Ultra
we're going to be getting such a huge
graphics performance now I didn't run
any benchmarks myself but reading this
article it says the M2 Ultra is only 10
slower than the RTX 4080 which is
nvidia's second fastest GPU right behind
their 4090s so
um yeah that's pretty impressive Apple's
come into play I mean they're not coming
to play like they're freaking here like
Intel Macs have 100 been left behind
like a silicon Mac chips are by far
better than anything that I could have
ever hoped for all right let's start a
new game um we're gonna do casual
this looks so good okay so right now I
have this set in just the standard
settings but we can actually go in
because this is the M2 Ultra and we can
actually make this look even better
because we can turn on the metal effects
upscaling 3840 by 2160 we're going to
prioritize the quality this is wild
because you can actually go in and see
the different quality
changing
I don't know if you guys can see this
but holy
what the heck this looks so freaking
Crystal Clear like her sweater looks
like everything looks so realistic I'm
actually so shook what a huge difference
that made Hello child I wasn't listening
and I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing do I put the child to sleep so I
did all the searching and I found a baby
carriage so hopefully this is where we
warm up we can go for a walk with the
child
okay well no we don't
shh where where is your crib yeah you're
going in here go see so now that we're
rid of the child
um we can actually move around here a
little bit faster and you can definitely
tell like all of the reflections like
everything is super super smooth what
kind of food you got is she okay what
kind of meal are you making okay
hit me
scenes look beautiful oh my goodness
quite a tragedy oh my God I'm scared
it's really late and I'm playing a scary
game
can I can I take any of that no
that is the question what looks like
it's now daytime look
how great this looks so gaming on this
was actually pretty impressive and I'm
really excited that I now have this
awesome setup that I feel like every
time I come home to visit I will have a
complete workstation so I'll be able to
bring this Mac Studio back and forth I
definitely plan on playing this in
between my work sessions this is pretty
great because now that I have this
workstation here I feel like I'm going
to be so much more productive when I do
come home to visit and now that we
actually have starlink internet it is so
much faster than before it's still not
as fast as my Los Angeles two gig up two
gig downs but considering that I could
barely browse the internet before
starlink is a savior well thank you guys
so much for watching I would love to
hear if there's anything else that you
would like to see me test out with the
Mac Studio be sure to leave all of those
in the comments below and if you guys
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and be sure to subscribe and
hit the Bell to be notified when I post
new videos if you want to check out any
more of my reviews you can check them
out here on the end screen with that my
friends I'll see you guys in the next
video bye